look at this isn't right by 22 second
challenge too much you I blocking the
way what's up guys welcome back to the
couch it's just me and tomorrow today
and real cozy you're real cozy gotta
keep warm because it's showing it's
bloody freezing and I paying the coldest
game the deadest game we are outside the
dentist team in the world some reference
in that chicken shop video anyway before
we play steep because it's winter this
is a wintry game seemed to fit that's
all we need so Vanitas leo another
enough of a CO until you mix up with
gimmick I've actually I actually
expected to be really bored by this game
but it's actually pretty good it's
tricky to rock a rhyme to rock around
does right on time it's tricky maybe
fall over and now you've sung that I
just want to play SSX tricky yes is this
anything like SSX tricky but i know
because that's my off I believe what
else he's not funny games on Bobby there
is a little bit like yet is it better
than tricky if the answer is no don't
care if you answer is yes don't care I
tricky it's like it's trickier than
tricky oh no it has our first then
tricky um but it has some tricks that
has less tricks and Ricky with the
tricks are trickier to pull off the
tricky does it have mobi in it no as in
the character model cannot be not the
bald guy yeah does it have movie tonight
it has me in it I'm currently dressed in
he leaves why do you look like a sniper
ghost Warrior II character that's that's
that's the has a gimmick I'm I'm
traveling to my it's my sty possessed on
a snowboard by james bond character
baetis snow fight over is that a sniper
over there just kinda line through snow
how would you see those in a ghillie
suit ladies that a sniper in there I
don't know he's at a getting sorted know
[ __ ] out of control snowboard
to me someone needs to stop their
snowboard for attending for force of
nature one thing I did like this game
though is that I've been playing it for
a few hours and
it's both like if I want to relax and
play it I've ruin this again if I relax
and play it you can just like you know
relax and chill and do some snowboarding
if you want to do like six [ __ ] though
not to do that you can do that so bad a
game it's quite a this is quite tricky
yeah it's tricky is a lot of emphasis on
the physics isn't that yeah like to the
point where you see how many g-forces
you just hit when you break a bone is it
realistic because I saw you going at
g-forces earlier that looked like they
would well as far as I know they would
like crush a human skeleton yeah I
crashed it like 300 G's before and I was
like my bones would be liquid that but
that man should be pasted that that
snipers mission is over sniper d is dead
mission fails we'll get them next time
oh god there's like eight be Willa what
I'm just gonna like go through some
sports and maybe try and gets like
highest mountain yeah snowboarding's
actually favored them yeah this is like
google google earth / maps style my
presentation right let's do it that's a
thing about it you pull out to our map
and you can pretty much teleport
anywhere you want yeah you have to get
like helicopter rides the points you
want where you can go to base camps
either helicopter is cooler than the one
in Forza horizon Bruno it's just it's
just low discreet unacceptable I'll get
you just it why have you done this oh
god I think playing this would like a
group of friends yeah just like full
snowboarding down the same rigs together
will be pretty cool I just hurt myself
badly can you punch each other is there
a road rash and merciless there should
be that will be pretty cool we were
playing this on pc so modest get to work
it's give everyone wrenches and like
smart rabbit you do this everyone who
sees what this is my boys it's it's made
me want to go snowboarding which is
something i've never actually done i
don't think i could snowboard i tried to
ski but because my legs are broken I
can't ski because my legs point outwards
yeah so if i try to ski it's like I'm
permit you trying to come to a stop and
I just don't move non-stop snowboarding
though
I used to skate it's the same bond snow
minute probably probably that's why I
hear the word the street the word on the
street is this game he pulls a snowboard
so tell me have you ever seen tony hawk
on a snowboard no but me I bracken if
you do it what is he like 50 now yeah
he's gone he's like a hundred years old
and he's still like oh god I'm and corn
was skateboards how did I get a gold
medal that was awful so we got we have
got for sports skiing and snowboarding a
pretty much the same but then it's like
paragliding and what's your don t on get
outta here because like the game is
looks realistic and it's quite grounded
it's very like simple in terms of like
what it's trying to present yeah like
here's a mounting it looks very clean
now in like and then like the UI is like
it trick to rock around the trailer
mystery key is like extreme sports but
then dial down but let me go back up and
then dial does really doesn't know what
it is it's a mismatch I found like cuz
were you earlier when you face-planted
into the side of a mountain at nine
billion geez friggin squirrel just
popped up was like ah well that's it
kind of minds me of skate in that way
like skate was quite similar see you
later E but then like you just
rag-dolled across things as well yeah
that was a part of and I think this this
objective on now is basically this guy
wants me to make a sick GoPro video oh
god that's only 11 Gees I'd be okay for
that so I got it I need to do all these
objectives first one is like oh hey go
to this mountain and then just you know
right to the other one letter for gas
nothing Las Vegas is on a mountain
is that a player yeah the deals really
embarrassing when you're when you're
like going down slopes with other
players and then they're doing sick
flips and you try to emulate it and then
you just fall see when I paid at a
preview I realized that there was an
actual like faceplant button and i spent
about 10 minutes just straight face
funny constantly and I had wanted I
didn't realize that one of the
developers of the gun was just standing
behind me I i found it endlessly amusing
to face plant and the dude behind me was
like why play my game actually is this
this is like 10 years of my life and
you're his face party oh god the snow
physics on it though like that was the
first thing that stood out to me I'm
nearly actually made a snow each other
oh can you whip it out and pee in a snap
no I mean why does it game exists
something's leavin modest to work on
models get to it like you'll be amazing
if you could like hit the P button hold
it down and you just peeing and then
your friends can see a trail to follow
that's how you make the trail how bad I
see you I can snowboard any person I am
time and what they may not get frostbite
on my business i I can't climb that just
walk you can get off as well so this is
the fifth spot this is it walking this
is you're getting in your snipers perch
ya go I'm gonna go all out for one shot
one kill I've got a sniper rifle
disguises that's a nice touch a little
klein I help me there's no way he'd be
able to do that though no he'd be
falling also on the shot as networks and
now I need to reach the Schwartz and
ease across just like climbing stairs
bits I'm gonna say let's try the skis
makers of her shoe that one only posting
everywhere there's a time to parachute
I'd like I like eight feet of drop it
has enough time for the deploy I think
it's the perfect i bring back faceplants
sick browse the tricks a very basic you
and you'd like to share some grabs but
then again like how many compared to SSX
is like hey do it 10 million degrees
spin and a superman and take your skis
off and helicopter with them and then
put it back on for you land get on with
it we've got confetti waiting got some
fireworks ready to roll I have to know
about that oh that part the game weight
which is fireworks and time we did a
trick yeah the skis there you go
backwards I want a Madison I know we're
paying steep it but I want a an SSX
remake of tricky just remake tricky
don't give me that new open world got
just giving me someone what's the SSX it
was kind of open world though yeah that
was the one that a the loss of his I 63
yeah it was okay but I need the tricky I
need the anything personally I need to
run DMC I don't know where I'm going we
got there no man I've gone the incorrect
way do skiers have access to jet packs
you might need that let's just get an
air balloon instead screw this run this
guy's GoPro videos every way unlocked
from the outset now you got to get like
certain levels to get certain things
like that air balloon is a level about
the maths itself 11 air balloon but if
you have a helicopter ticket you can
kind of go anywhere like I think this is
the highest point in the game so we
could just try and go there my blog matt
LeBlanc mount Leblanc
so I think this is one of the highest
points the game maybe we just try and
get his cut the bomb smoke dank weed
guys play the game again where are we
going there make sure we go I say you I
say you bring out the squirrel suit
because everything I played of the game
and seen at the game the square root is
the one man yeah it's the most fun and
it's infuriating to control it really is
which equals illness my by nose face
plants all right give a wing suit yes
there are no that is it the faith you
mind doing that for 10 solid minutes
just put instances of yourself and then
turning around and seeing mr. Ubisoft me
like why I don't know how I did that I
think is that why not try again whatever
the jump is but if you just don't commit
to the job now I'm just walking x 0 so
I'm just in walking mode if i switch to
body mode no game of the year then it
goes honey go into walking where you
remember g-force that movie about
squirrels was it so gerbils gerbils and
that was actually put that in a script
screenplay recently which is why i have
remember that hot trash that movie maybe
I should ski to a point or snowboard to
a point where it is funny again if I
should I this high enough aim that's
like a little bit we like a sheer cliff
face something remember after all that
no
I was gonna clean my room oh that guy
and then I gotta go Tommy yes click oh
he's kind of like now God my balance is
how it just falls off as well reckon I
could just jump off this have like the
lamest wing see right over can you
change we made it oh can you change your
midday know fairly pretty sick if you
can go like from a wingsuit into like a
snowboard yes I'm hoping you be able to
do oh this it's really hard not to the
baseball right but it's cuz it's in wing
sumo do you just give in to the foot you
leveled up for it up for facebook it's
getting all tricky again with the
animals will get together it's tricky do
you have antlers yes this game is good
product placed here like crazy right oh
yeah there's like I've already had one
for like redbull gopro 3 o's man do how
we do actually it's only Red Bull ago
products on the road for gopro but they
show all that yeah like loads of courses
are sponsored by north face or like
brands of snowboard or something you're
wondering why your sales on matter to
the toll of this game that's way hey go
they got that money already i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go this rock was this guy
doing yes you stuck your views online
how am I supposed to get sick kill
streaks like this I'm gonna go up here
the game just doesn't like being on rock
yeah you'd like lose all your stamina
just k oh we've gotta do at least want
to do the do the flying through the ring
yeah go go that way turn straight away
do the flying for the Rings missions for
now like I mean turn looks like a troll
oh there we go grazed Noah know
raise your special place the way to get
points in wings is to basically get
close to stuff so it's like it risked
your life and you get points yeah so
it's like near misses in burn up yeah
much exactly that's going on there these
are all like ice collects dolls and set
him this is like for Gil minerals
expecting much fun oh fancy it's gonna
be like a starcraft 2 mineral collector
just turn it up let me guess it doesn't
seem like you've got a lot of speed here
no like this is sliding I'm when you go
in horizontal you're fairly slow but
when you like sorry that all about how
you maintain this momentum but also a
nice knife I don't know where I'm going
I'm just gonna try and get to the bottom
of the mountain without dying we're
waiting all this like razor-sharp ice
glass Oh God hey kilometers all right
you got Explorer achievement or also one
split over daddy's architects oh no my
testes that was right in the pretty sure
I just liquidize my group that was an
amazing leg fall he's straight of is my
rag doll you've been smoked man that hot
so sold it so you want to do the super
hard rock glide child you out on that
well that's just death no there is
that's it if she needs to use this info
look at this isn't right 22 second
challenge too much you i blocking the
way oh look there is a gopher he's
wearing a little hat go for a beanie
yeah the UI it just like blocks this
first hole if you know what I mean 260
g-force have a Google real quick how
many g-forces does it take to kill a
person because I'm definitely dead
though right loaded this I'm mostly very
early okay was kind of curly treehouse
Eric yeah all right there we go live
series series rats
rice no way so he's not working fine
doesn't know if recognize your accent
doesn't let me hold Siri how many
g-forces does it take to kill a person
lets me check on that oh here's what I
found on the web for how many g-forces
does it take to kill a person ah yeah
ever she sends a car by that this is so
difficult 371 z for such hitter this is
bogus for example almost everyone put in
a centrifuge trainer would get knocked
out when the trainer go from one g to
sustained 9g in about one second so
unconsciousness is a 9g line g ok yeah
what about strip death anything over 10
is in the danger zone what the hell does
320 do anything over 10 is in the danger
zone I just hit a hundred ninety-seven
190 something is probably like you don't
exist like your house becomes player x
basically deconstruct and reconstruct so
that you never existed it's like I seen
it I and man we go so small yeah it's
like everyone forgets for you everywhere
oh that one you gotta hit the brakes and
plummet straight away there are no
brakes become a log into the toilet
this is this is a thing a thing that's
like so infuriating that I'll never do
it yeah but I've also i'm also like too
proud to give up on it don't even
respect you i need to give you away I go
for was wearing a suicide vest like zoom
in on ya there's a dog the st. Bernard
with a broken leg just made me sad man
right this challenge is happening I'll
do I'll do it a slight easy one alright
so to end this video I'm gonna go up to
the top of this mountain high as I can
go I'm just gonna try I mean it go as
far as I can the moment I KO or wipe out
that's the end of video I kind of want
to play this game I mean it's more
better than I thought it was cuz seems
like a good podcast game yeah it's a
good answer a sex story is my no she's
like you're a guy oh man which way
should we go down this way I reckon if
we go down here here and there that's
all rocky though but ba ba ba ba ba
that's kind of expensive there's no
story no it's like there's a voice if
it's not your head over the radios
basically saying hey get sponsorships
and go through six year that's one of
them stories yeah I like it when sports
games go in on the story and make it as
stupid as possible like they featured
legit Joe agreements MBA that [ __ ] was
bonkers it's tony hawk's games it's like
you need to save something he needs like
raise all this money to save the skate
park or some [ __ ] the NBA game was like
you got to get your boys at the hood
then you get out of hood and one of your
boys gets jealous and he dies eventually
and I suggesting at the end like
watching a carnival NBA is at least like
NBA 2k 17
the latest one maybe it's last year's
one but I disappear the end we're in a
basketball court and his ghost comes
back what all your dunking it's pretty
cool I go to the honking past you know I
had a great story def jam vendetta and
fight for New York do you not play those
games much a wrestling game with all
rappers main song it's pretty amazing
and Snoop Dogg is like the arch-villain
it's called The Crow I love there like
use the Eiffel in this game and now
what's new you're doing a cooking show
this is LSU and selling legal weed sike
it's a change to look absolutely
incredible confident this run live event
for myself is pretty lame so finest run
over sure boys its outlying glitches or
is that oh it's getting to look like a
thunderstorm for a second knows but see
it's on thunderstorm she's gonna get
real okay it's on now okay we go we're
picking up some speed there is a break
in this but i think i've ever used it
many people fought last night but right
now I'll think about me what am I gonna
shoot though it's rocks meal oh god this
looks hella hella dangerous my bloody
screen so real again that's like kind of
a photo stylized SSX tricky thing really
if you lose your stamina grey screen
this looks dangerous white people
hanging out here oh nice nice zeiss how
do I going I thought was going into a
tunnel I've not been to this part of the
game yet scary Glacia like I don't know
it looks like every other part again
white cold more yet you see is what you
get me i bought this snowboarding game
right and everything was just quite
enjoyed where's the earth how much snow
and where's the environment variation
excited tester yes sir throne Bethesda
under the bus shouldn't no reason there
is the snowboarding games about too much
now in it thanks a lot faster ha this is
me dead this is definitely dead I didn't
care didn't care sick board that was
first light on it it's a boy myself Oh
ipe to this guy nah I'm good listen I
just fell over I said I KO when UK up
yeah remember that thing comes up my
dishonored since trigger that's like I'm
be spied I leave hired crouch I think
you get knocked out when you hit a
hundred G's oh god
I keep landing all these jumps really
sloppy loser Miss Hannah story my life
sloppy jumps yeah sloppy jumps me the
right name for a rapper general waste
that's my rep general waste zeros
landfill 470 from landfill coming in
2017 we go down this class it's going to
require let me do it let's give you
trash general wait wait you're close
enough to unlock a drop zone yeah but
I'm going like a hundred miles an hour
so I can't exactly bring out my
binoculars I just caught something oh I
was a rock it's not looking good my
sniper mr. border I have a name I'm
giving this a story this is this is like
the world's most lost night but well you
play as Pro snowboarders and like beat
that the first part of the first
character named what I got the old water
Matt Hoffman must be nice when I started
the game you can although this crate I
was just you know Zeus off there it's no
bother Tom clunky what I'm sure they
could I bet you this what I sold more if
it's tom clancy's deep if they if they
had done tom clancy steep where you
played a military dude like a soldier
snowboarding sniper point I bet you this
would be a much more popular game
because then you can do popular now I
imagine it'd be anywhere I was a another
game I was just giving a default
character that was white with brown hair
and a beard and I was like okay so its
face scanned me that I turned out I was
given an actual real-life snowboarder to
play us and then I immediately covered
his face of the skull and put on the
ghillie suit like an occasional player
in this game what would you breach and
clear is like hardest Idol heaven your
boys are already there waiting feet and
then just he's coming down the mountain
go go go and he's come well wings to
throw away here on skis just like slap
down some c4 on the way through just
make it a sound like it either be it
either be the snowboard seen from xxx
more the crap ski see from the is it
tomorrow never dies yes god damn well
you are you were gone it's like 72 hours
call his parents this is that James
Franco movie yeah he's stuck in between
the two rocks is where I got out without
cut my arm off mate don't obviously no
one would find you down here don't over
said it sequently moms in the air he's
cut yeah mate you just check himself
over get up don't just shake it off get
up I thought we was like giving respect
to the mountain that's on me thanks for
letting me live I wrecked my [ __ ] haha
if you crash down there ain't nobody I
don't know one timing especially
considering i mean mollis large and like
an equally lost penguin my koala I saw a
player earlier and he was the outfit was
wearing was he was wearing a white hat a
white jacket on white trousers and like
I know it's fake but it gave me anxiety
so if this was if you went snowboarding
you dressed all in white if I was
actually on a mountain and there's
someone dressed on the one I was like
you you're wishing for death yeah what
are you doing he's clearly a criminai
like I'm gonna be in like bright lime
green or orange or something I'm gonna
set myself on fire I'm just gonna be
wearing LEDs just Hawaii why is there a
rave going down that mountain that'd be
sick though yeah we had those like silam
sticks that you can turn into bracelet
is wearing sowwie those and so I random
old lady wearing one yeah I ramen
restaurant it really is we're a family
and I she's just wearing one of those
glow stick baby I was like what's going
on here how one gets that Lake right
we're gonna get to that Lake I no
contact I think assuming the lake is
frozen oh I did a quad flip before from
sickest you're gonna go down there gonna
be water temple haha blame
it's just like a SEAL team under the
world waiting for me mp5 the red hoc all
team made of seagulls freezing that ass
off yeah loaded up with explosives
picture there was actually military
seals and dolphins yea yea trained to
put mines and hulls of ships then why's
up to it and used we're not getting good
and the Dolphins the Dolphins knew the
sea lions are like what's going on get a
dolphin to a location you guys should do
this your way better this thing we are
we're gonna we're gonna watch and learn
from guys go go for it blood everywhere
this this looks frozen man all right I'm
bang is from it's like a stag texture I
mean that just might be useful I'm
kidding I'm kidding they make good
world's just played a very sign another
house I'm sliding wait they see me slide
in those eight G's as agents no I see
you like that is a lie again Tommy it
gives you AG eight point six genes way
man all right well we made the ball of
mine I think I'm all snowboarder though
I need to like go to a Shelly yeah I
just blew behind a blanket brandy it's
real cold in here and in the game well
if you liked this video make sure you
hit the like button subscribe for more
dumb us play more dumb games it appears
to our place um SSX tricky let us know
if that cheat code the time we can check
out what you good Simon is revered you
got this extra key ok get online and at
your more on Twitter and be like where
is SSX tricky remake what you doing with
your legs and then he'll reply I'm head
of eSports and you were like because I
saw you in the game what's talking to
boogie you look like you could do
something I love this little narrative
leave me up just anyway don't fall down
no mines don't try this at home they
actually have that big in the game don't
fall them bones don't heal try this out
don't hit 300 g by hitting your brain
we'll see you next time
it's my that subscribe button match that